Lucy Edwards lost her sight at 17. what
page is a recipe for soup question mark
now she's helping to test be my eyes an
app running arguably the most powerful
AI language model ever developed gpt4
can understand human words and pictures
so this is why it's incredible because
now I've got all of these cookery books
at my disposal for her AI is changing
the world so the potential you think is
life-changing as a disabled person you
do have to give up your autonomy in in
some different ways and I believe that
AI is the closest thing for me to not
have to give a autonomy and it's just me
and my tech in unity as part of a move
to attract the best AI companies to
Britain the Science and Technology
secretary is now introducing the UK's
plan to regulate it but not with new
laws in terms of legislation for AI
we're not saying never ever legislation
what we're saying is at the moment we
have an emerging technology if we
produce legislation now it will be out
of date in literally a year but while
the potential benefits of AI are
incalculable so too are the risks
taking this information these fake
images of Donald Trump being arrested by
police were painted in pixels by an AI
depicting an event that never happened
companies using AI say regulation is
essential for public confidence anybody
really responsible sees that there are
potential downsides to the tech to the
technology but I think we also see
societally enormous upside but you know
look it's it's almost like anything else
people want to know the rules in the
framework and people want to progress
technology but do so safely so
regulation is essential I never thought
that I would be able to be completely
independent again there's hardly a
better example of trust in technology
than someone blind using it to see the
responsibility AI places on big Tech and
those who regulate it has never been
greater
Tom Clark Sky News people